This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中探讨我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养坚毅品质的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和当时的我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英语。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾有朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那真的是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
欢迎在iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方订阅收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《迎难而上》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不够安全的坦诚对话。但在这里，你是在和一个经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
欢迎在iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方订阅收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个男人也遭遇了同样的事情。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。欢迎在iHeart radio app、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean. for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we're talking about something that we've actually never spoken about on the podcast before, which is honestly shocking because when it comes to our 20s, one of the universal, relatable, joint experiences of people during this decade is living with other people, is the sharehouse, communal living, flatting, whatever you want to call it. And a lot about that experience is deeply psychological, how we learn to live with others, how we communicate,
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，我们将一起剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我们要聊一个我们在播客中从来没有聊过的话题，老实说这挺让人震惊的，因为说到20多岁，在这个十年里，人们普遍经历的、能引起共鸣的共同经历之一，就是与其他人一起生活，也就是合租屋、群居生活、合租公寓，随你怎么称呼它。这种经历背后其实蕴含着深刻的心理学，比如我们如何学会与他人相处，我们如何沟通，
our relationships, the conflict, the tension. The psychology is really everywhere in that dynamic. I think our 20s are often that time for many of us, when, we take the leap to move out of our childhood home, our family home, and really forge kind of our own independent lives. It's a huge hallmark of this decade. I guess we just outgrow the family environment. We don't feel like a child anymore. We want our own space. And often the most kind of economically viable option is to move in with a group of other people, our own age. I think not only is that sometimes the only thing we can afford, let's be real. But a lot of this is that these are people that we share the same lifestyle with. And it's kind of like a ride of passage, such a valuable
我们的人际关系、冲突、紧张气氛。在这种动态中，心理学无处不在。我认为20多岁对我们很多人来说，通常就是那个我们迈出一步，搬离童年和家庭住宅，真正开创自己独立生活的时期。这是这个年代的一个巨大标志。我想我们只是长大了，不再适合家庭环境了。我们不再觉得自己是个孩子了。我们想要自己的空间。通常来说，最经济实惠的选择就是和一群同龄人合租。我认为这不仅有时是我们唯一负担得起的方式，说实话。而且很大程度上是因为这些人与我们有着相同的生活方式。这有点像一个成长的仪式，是一次非常宝贵的
social experience to see how we live with others, to maybe make lifelong friends, to build our own community that is separate from the family unit. But it's also not that straightforward. I've been living in sharehouses or dorms with roommates since I was 17, for the last seven years, that is way too long. And of course, I think like anyone who has done their time, I have some stories. We might, you know, romanticize this way of living and the chaos and the group dinners and the movie nights, whatever it may be. But the people we choose to live with are sometimes the most important people in our lives. And so it's kind of make or break, depending on how well we actually get along. We are sharing a home together, which if you think about it,
社交经历，能让我们了解如何与他人生活，也许能结交终身的朋友，建立一个独立于家庭之外的属于我们自己的社群。但事情也没那么简单。我从17岁开始就一直在合租屋或宿舍里和室友一起生活，过去的七年里一直如此，这时间实在是太长了。当然，我想任何经历过这段时光的人都有一些故事要讲。我们可能会（你知道的）将这种生活方式浪漫化，比如那些混乱、集体晚餐、电影之夜，无论那是什么。但我们选择与之同住的人，有时却是我们生命中最重要的人。因此，根据我们实际相处的融洽程度，这可以说是成败在此一举。我们同住一个屋檐下，如果你仔细想想，
it is like the most sacred space that a human can have. It is our place of comfort, of safety, of security. We sleep under the same roof as these people. We see them constantly. And their choices impact our quality of life. There was actually one piece of research published on this in 2016. And it indicates that the people who we live with, impact everything from our eating habits, our exercise habits, our sleeping habits, in both a positive and a negative direction, particularly through things like peer pressure or observational learning and the adoption of like communal values. And depending on your experience, that can actually be really great. We can become really thick and fast friends.
这可以说是人类能拥有的最神圣的空间了。这是我们感到舒适、安全和有保障的地方。我们和这些人睡在同一个屋檐下。我们不断地见到他们。他们的选择影响着我们的生活质量。2016年其实曾发表过一篇关于这方面的研究。它表明，我们与之同住的人，会影响我们的饮食习惯、运动习惯、睡眠习惯等方方面面，既有积极的影响也有消极的影响，特别是通过同辈压力、观察学习以及共同价值观的采纳等途径。根据你的经历，这其实可以是一件非常棒的事情。我们可以成为非常亲密且进展神速的朋友。
For example, in Korea, they surveyed nearly a thousand young single adults. living in share housing, and they found that people who were living with a roommate reported feeling less lonely and more socially supported. So there are definitely a lot of benefits. But when that turns sour, when we're met with conflict, different personalities, different standards for cleanliness, when we move in with friends and we begin to see a different side of someone now that we share a bathroom or a kitchen with them, that is when I think the sharehouse truly becomes a real like psychological petri dish. Conflict or tension in a home has a massive effect on our mental well-being.
例如，在韩国，他们调查了近千名居住在合租房里的年轻单身成年人，发现与室友同住的人报告说感到不那么孤独，得到了更多的社会支持。所以这绝对有很多好处。但当这种关系变味时，当我们面临冲突、不同的性格、不同的清洁标准时，当我们和朋友合租，却发现对方有了新的一面——因为现在我们要和他们共用浴室或厨房时，我认为合租屋就真正变成了一个现实中的“心理学培养皿”。家庭中的冲突或紧张关系对我们的心理健康有着巨大的影响。
And there have been so many studies, articles, research projects on this, particularly amongst young adults. Because if you think about it, you're basically putting two, three, four, sometimes more people together in a small environment all of whom have different backgrounds, expectations, lifestyles, and we're just kind of praying that it works. And so a sharehouse is kind of its own social experiment on how relationships are formed, how we communicate, how we interact, how relationships break down. And that is really what I want to explore today. We are going to discuss what makes a good roommate, different types of roommates,
关于这一点，已经有无数的研究、文章和科研项目，特别是在年轻人当中。因为如果你仔细想想，你基本上是把两三个、三四个甚至更多背景、期望、生活方式各不相同的人塞进一个小环境里，而我们只能祈祷它能顺利运转。因此，合租屋本身就是一场关于人际关系如何形成、我们如何沟通、如何互动以及人际关系如何破裂的社会实验。而这正是我今天想要探讨的内容。我们将讨论什么样的人是好室友，不同类型的室友，
the four different types of roommates and living styles, the dilemma of kind of moving in with friends and also what causes social harmony to break down when you are in a sharehouse. I also want to talk about what psychology has to say about creating a positive space, being a good roommate, dealing with conflict in the home, and also being able to recognize that moment when it is time to move out, when it is time to live alone. I think I'm getting to that point now. I've done my time. I've done my hours.
四种不同类型的室友和生活方式，与朋友合租的困境，以及是什么导致了你在合租屋里社交和谐的破裂。我还想探讨心理学对以下方面的看法：如何营造一个积极的空间、做一个好室友、处理家庭内部冲突，以及如何能够认清是时候搬出去、是时候独自生活的时刻。我想我现在正在接近那个节点。我已经熬过这段时间了。我已经完成了我的时数。
I've had the sharehouse experience. And I really just want to come home and not talk to anyone at this point. I kind of want to watch whatever I want to watch on TV and not have to like time my showers around other people. So I think I might only have like a few more months to actually be able to talk about this probably from like a lived experience. And that's what we're going to do today. So without further ado, I think it's about time we've been.
我已经体验过合租生活了，说实话，我真的只想回到家，在这个时候不想跟任何人说话。我只想在电视上看看我想看的东西，而不必掐着时间跟别人错开洗澡。所以我想我大概只有几个月的时间还能以亲身经历来谈论这个话题了。这就是我们今天要做的。所以，废话不多说，我想是时候开始了。
break down all of the psychology to do with communal living, sharehouses, and roommates. So let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts. and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
剖析所有与群居生活、合租屋和室友相关的心理学。让我们深入探讨吧。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将探讨我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养坚毅品质的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家进行对话。探讨更多内容，以抛弃主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I-Hard. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英语。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地讲述了80年代的快克可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
澄清一下，1984年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆上台面了，所以……谢谢你把那句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host,
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。欢迎在iHeart radio app、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方订阅收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人，
and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们把生活当成记分牌来看待，生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为老兄，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是这样。这是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct?
我希望你真的能发自内心地做一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio app。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探出动才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The move to share housing from the family home, whether you're living with complete strangers or friends, whoever, it's really exciting.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。欢迎在iHeart radio app、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。从家庭住宅搬到合租房，无论你是和完全陌生的人还是和朋友同住，无论和谁一起，都真的非常令人兴奋。
Like we can't overstate the anticipation and like fun of getting to buy your own bowls and picking out your bed sheets and being able to have a space that is your own and separate from your parents and your siblings, whoever else is in your house. It honestly just feels like super adult. It's like one of those experiences I think we look at and we're like, oh yeah, this is the point where I felt like I was actually mature enough to call myself an adult human being. And then I think the social element of it is also super appealing, especially when you live with friends. It's like summer camp or a sleepover every night of the week. And it's the freedom that many of us, I think, have been aspiring towards since we were children. You know, it's kind of similar to having your own money. You get a space where you can live your life exactly how you would like it.
比如我们怎么也高估不了那种期待感，以及去买自己的碗、挑选床单、拥有一个属于自己的、独立于父母、兄弟姐妹以及屋里其他任何人的空间的乐趣。这老实说感觉超级像成年人。这就像是那种我们看着会觉得，“哦，对了，这就是我觉得自己终于成熟到可以称自己为一个成年人的时刻”的体验之一。然后我认为它的社交元素也非常吸引人，特别是当你和朋友合租时。这就像是一周七天每天都在夏令营或者开睡衣派对。这是我们许多人从小就一直渴望的自由。你知道的，这有点类似于有了自己的钱。你得到了一个空间，可以完全按照你喜欢的方式生活。
So I have this theory that the first six months of communal living are like the honeymoon period. It is the buzz of new things, of new relationships, or at least a new dimension to a relationship if you're living with friends, and this really new environment. But I think after that six months period is when the reality of constantly having to share your space with someone who is not related to you sinks in. The biggest thing we have to adapt to is different living styles because each of us has grown up in a certain unique environment, expecting certain levels of cleanliness. different rules, times that we want to rest, times that we want to socialize. People just to use their spaces differently. They treat them differently based on the home environment of their childhood. It's really interesting because there's been research on this and it's shown that how your
所以我有一个理论，合租生活的前六个月就像是蜜月期。那是新鲜事物带来的兴奋感，是新关系的兴奋感（如果你和朋友合租的话，至少是关系的新维度），还有这个全新的环境。但我认为在那个六个月的时期之后，必须不断与一个与你没有血缘关系的人共享空间的现实就会开始深入人心。我们必须适应的最主要的事情是不同的生活方式，因为我们每个人都在某个独特的环境中长大，对清洁度有着特定的期望。不同的规则、我们想要休息的时间、我们想要社交的时间。人们只是以不同的方式使用他们的空间。他们根据自己童年时的家庭环境来对待空间。这真的很有趣，因为这方面有过研究，研究表明你的
parents organized a home is going to be one of the biggest determinants for how you choose to treat your future living spaces. And it is natural, normal for those there to be kind of differences across people. The biggest one for me is the level of mess that we are willing to tolerate. I have noticed this in my own sharehouses and with my roommates where there is a distinction between wanting things tidy and wanting things clean. Some people just don't care if the floors aren't vacuumed or the couches are a little bit dirty as long as there are like no personal items in a communal space.
父母如何整理一个家，将是你选择如何对待未来居住空间的最大决定因素之一。而人们之间存在这种差异是自然且正常的。对我来说最主要的一点是，我们愿意容忍的凌乱程度。我在我自己的合租屋和室友身上注意到了这一点，那就是“希望东西整洁”和“希望东西干净”是有区别的。有些人根本不在乎地板有没有吸尘，或者沙发有没有点脏，只要公共空间里没有个人物品就行。
But others are totally fine with like a certain level of untidiness. as long as the house is sanitised. And then there are the housemates, the unique housemates, who just don't care, who are happy to live in absolute squalor. I often see this as a reaction to three things. Firstly, for these individuals who really don't care about mess or cleanliness, that was the standard that their parents set, whereby they also didn't really care about living amongst,
但其他人则完全可以接受一定程度的不整洁，只要家里是卫生消毒过的就行。然后还有一些室友，那些独特的室友，他们根本不在乎，乐意生活在绝对的肮脏环境里。我经常把这视为对三件事的反应。首先，对于那些真的不在乎凌乱或清洁的人来说，那是他们父母设定的标准，他们的父母也并不太在意生活在……
I'm not going to say filth, but just like literally, literally. amongst mess. Maybe it's because, yeah, they just really, they were completely apathetic to it, or be, they were too busy to deal with it. And so because that person has never known any differently, because they have adjusted to this lifestyle, they bring that to the sharehouse. They bring that to the environment. I had a roommate once who was so revolting. He would use, like, all of the glasses in our house for coffee and wine and beer, whatever. And then he would refuse to clean them. And so we stopped cleaning them as well. We were like, I don't want to be your like servant anymore, almost in like protest. Until every, I kid you not, every single glass in our house had like a layer of mold at the bottom.
我不会说那是污秽中，但确实就是字面意义上的。生活在凌乱之中。也许是因为，是的，他们真的，他们对之完全无动于衷，或者第二，他们太忙了，没空处理。正因为这个人从来不知道有什么不同，因为他们已经习惯了这种生活方式，他们把这带到了合租屋。他们把这带到了这个环境中。我曾经有一个室友，恶心透顶。他会用我们家里所有的杯子来喝咖啡、喝红酒、喝啤酒，随便什么都行。然后他拒绝清洗它们。于是我们也不帮他洗了。我们就好像是在抗议一样，心想：我可不想再当你的什么仆人。直到最后，我不骗你，我们家里的每一个杯子底部都长了一层霉。
We couldn't even use them. Eventually I actually, I took all of the glasses over to my friend's house. I put them through their dishwasher, brought them home, and hid them from him. And I told my other roommates, like, where they were. And for, like, weeks, we would have, like, a glass of water or whatever. We would finish. We would wash our glass and just, like, put it back in its hiding place until he kind of had to, like, come back to us with this, like, tail between his legs. There's just people like that who, like, do not care about filth.
我们甚至都用不了。最后我 faktisk（瑞典语：实际上）……我把所有的杯子都拿到我朋友家去。我把它们放进他们的洗碗机里洗干净，带回家，然后把它们藏了起来。我告诉了我的其他室友，它们在哪里。所以有几个星期，我们要喝水什么的。用完后我们自己洗干净杯子，然后把它放回藏匿的地方，直到他不得不带着像夹着尾巴的狗一样的神情来找我们。就是有这样的人，他们完全不在乎肮脏。
The second reaction is whereby we have these people who have grown up, in a really strict household where the level of cleanliness was like almost hospital-like and they move out of home and experience like a complete reversal in habits. They finally have like the freedom to treat their space as they would like it. And so they unconsciously counteract what was previously expected of them by going in the complete entire opposite direction. it's almost like a delayed childhood rebellion against the rules that were upheld by their parents. And also there's the other element of, you know, no one's asking them to be clean anymore.
第二种反应是，我们遇到了一些这样的人：他们在一个非常严格的家庭中长大，那里的清洁程度几乎像医院一样，结果他们搬出家门后，生活习惯发生了彻底的颠覆。他们终于有了自由，可以随心所欲地对待自己的空间。于是，他们下意识地通过走向完全相反的极端，来对抗以前对他们的期望。这几乎就像是对父母制定的规则的一种延迟的童年叛逆。而且还有另一个因素，你知道的，没有人再要求他们保持清洁了。
No one's asking them to keep their space tidy. And so they no longer have the motivation to self-enforce those levels of cleanliness. It's really interesting because this is actually a concept in psychology. It's known as the rebellion of the over-criticized child. But in these instances, often what we see is people who skip their childhood and teenage rebellion stage because the family environment was so strict. But then that emerges in adulthood when they start living with others, almost as a form of like emotional catharsis or release from the pressure they experienced as a child. And finally, there are situations in which one roommate has such a high standard for cleanliness that they are just willing to do all the work to keep their environment as they were the same. like it. And that results in what we would call free loading by the other members of the house. So
没有人要求他们保持空间整洁。因此，他们不再有动力去自我约束那些清洁水平。这真的很有趣，因为这实际上是心理学中的一个概念。它被称为“过度批评的孩子的叛逆”。但在这些情况下，我们经常看到的是那些跳过了童年和青少年叛逆阶段的人，因为他们的家庭环境太严格了。但这种叛逆却在成年后他们开始与他人同住时爆发了，几乎成为了一种情绪宣泄，或是从他们小时候经历的压力中释放出来的一种形式。最后，还有这样一种情况：其中一个室友对清洁的标准如此之高，以至于他们愿意做完所有的家务，以保持环境符合他们喜欢的样子。这就导致了其他家庭成员的“搭便车”行为。所以
freeloading is actually an economics term whereby we see people take advantage of other people's generosity or efforts. Sometimes unconsciously, they've just come to expect this from the other person. Sometimes they like engage in the delusion that, oh yeah, my roommate claims because it makes them happy or they don't even notice. Yet they still benefit from this person's like additional labor in the house. I like to call this type of roommate the Cinderella roommate. Obviously, in the fairy tale, Cinderella,
搭便车其实是一个经济学术语，指的是我们看到有人利用别人的慷慨或努力。有时是无意识的，他们只是习惯了从另一个人身上期望得到这个。有时他们甚至陷入一种妄想，觉得“哦，是的，我的室友收拾是因为这让他们高兴，或者他们根本没注意到。”然而他们仍然受益于这个人对家里额外付出的劳动。我喜欢把这种类型的室友称为“灰姑娘室友”。显然，在童话故事中，灰姑娘，
Cinderella is the one who keeps everything clean in the background. She does all the washing, all the sweeping, the dishes for her step-sisters without any appreciation. I would say that most houses have a Cinderella. And often, these people are also very deep people-pleases. So they won't say anything
灰姑娘就是在幕后保持一切清洁的人。她为继姐妹们做所有的洗涤、所有的扫地、洗碗，却没有得到任何感激。我想说，大多数家庭都有一个灰姑娘。而且通常，这些人也是非常深的老好人。所以他们什么都不会说，
until it kind of like boils over and explodes. Or they just become so resigned to the mess that they let everything get disgusting and then even more frustrated when nobody does anything whilst the other roommates don't really like pick up on that and they're just waiting, expecting this person to eventually get to a point of like such deep frustration that they'll just go back to cleaning everything all over again. It's super unfair. It is super unfair. and I think the existence of a Cinderella points to a very important psychological truth about
直到这种情绪像火山一样爆发。或者他们对杂乱变得如此顺从，以至于任由一切变得令人作呕，然后当没有人做任何事而其他室友根本没有察觉到这一点时，他们会变得更加沮丧，那些室友只是在等待、期待这个人最终达到一种深度沮丧的程度，以至于他们会重新开始打扫一切。这超级不公平。这真的超级不公平。而且我认为灰姑娘的存在指出了关于合租屋的一个非常重要的心理学真理：
sharehouses. Each roommate is going to take on a certain social role in the house, the same way that each of us takes on a role in the family home. And those roles sometimes are going to come into conflict. So the best way to understand this, I think, is through this theory called the styles of life theory. This was originally introduced by this psychiatrist, Alfred Adler. You might know him because he coined the term inferiority complex. But he also came up with this theory that each of us has a unique, unconscious and repetitive way of responding to or avoiding the main tasks of life. That includes friendships, love, work, behavior, or relationships in the home. obviously he wasn't applying this theory to like the relationship between roommates in the 21st century
每个室友都会在家里承担某种社会角色，就像我们每个人在家庭中承担角色一样。而这些角色有时会产生冲突。我认为理解这一点的最好方法是通过一个叫做“生活风格理论”的理论。这个理论最初是由精神病学家阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒提出的。你可能知道他，因为他创造了“自卑情结”这个词。但他也提出了这样一个理论：我们每个人都有独特、无意识且重复的方式来应对或逃避生活的主要任务。这包括友谊、爱情、工作、行为或家庭中的关系。显然，他并没有将这个理论应用于21世纪室友之间的关系，
but when we take his core ideas they have a lot of applicability so there are four styles or roles that we can take on in the share home so there's the ruling type this person is the leader they might take care of the bills maybe they were like the OG housemate or renter, they feel more of a sense of like possessiveness or control over the home. They are more liberal with using communal spaces. They host parties. It kind of feels like it's their home. Then we have the getting type. The ones who don't really do anything, they take rather than give. They take advantage of the other members in the house. We have the avoiding type, the one who is kind of like never there who like very much doesn't take part in sharehouse activities kind of stays out of
但当我们采用他的核心思想时，它们具有很大的适用性。因此，我们在合租房中可以承担四种生活风格或角色：有统治型，这个人是领导者，他们可能会负责账单，也许他们是最初的室友或租户，他们对这个家有更多的所有权或控制感。他们在公共空间的使用上更随性。他们举办派对。这感觉更像是他们的家。然后我们有索取型。那些不怎么做事的人，他们习惯索取而不是付出。他们占其他家庭成员的便宜。我们有回避型，那种好像从来不在家的人，非常不参与合租屋的活动，有点置身于
conflict stays out of the way is a bit of a ghost and finally we have the socially useful type this is very similar to the cinderella archetype they kind of contribute more than all the others but they're also more likely to have like a social interest in keeping the peace and they really like a certain level of social activity. Each of us in a sharehouse takes on one of these roles. It's really interesting because I know which one I am and I'm pretty sure I could easily assign every single roommate I've ever had to one of these roles, like easily. And you don't have to be a house of four. Like you can be a house of two or three or five or six because some people can take on the same role, but also there can be people who only take on one role and there is one left out.
冲突之外，置身事外，有点像个幽默的幽灵。最后我们有社会有用型，这非常类似于灰姑娘原型，他们比其他人贡献更多，但他们也更有可能对维持和平抱有社会兴趣，并且他们真的很喜欢某种程度的社交活动。我们在合租屋里每个人都承担着这些角色之一。这真的很有趣，因为我知道自己是哪一种，而且我很确定我可以轻松地把我住过的每一个室友都归入这些角色之一，简直轻而易举。而且你们不需要是一个四人的房子。你们可以是一个两人、三人、五人或六人合租的房子，因为有些人可以承担相同的角色，但也可能有人只承担某种角色，而有一个角色被空置。
So I think that this theory is one of the best psychological explanations for why we have different sharehouse or roommate like personalities and archetypes. Beyond these kinds of prototypes, I've already mentioned it, but we have the kind of added nuance of personality. Each of us is going to come to the table, not just with a different background and a different set of standards, but a different set of attributes and personality traits, which kind of influence how easy it really is the, you know, people to get along with you. I often think about this according to the big five personality traits in psychology, so these are openness, conscientiousness, extroversion, agreeableness, and neuroticism.
所以我认为这个理论是对我们为什么会有不同的合租屋或室友性格和原型的最好心理学解释之一。除了这些原型之外，我之前已经提到过了，我们还有人格带来的额外微妙之处。我们每个人来到这里，不仅带着不同的背景和不同的标准，还带着一套不同的属性和人格特质，这在某种程度上决定了人们真正与你相处有多容易。我经常根据心理学中的“大五人格特质”来思考这一点，这五个特质是开放性、尽责性、外向性、宜人性和神经质。
Out of those five kind of big five personality traits, each of us sits somewhere along the spectrum of each of them. And if you've ever done the Maya Briggs personality test, you can kind of based on this combination, determine what kind of person you are and also what kind of person you're going to be in a communal environment. Like maybe you are the entertainer or the executive or the mediator, the debater, the commander. I don't know which one you are, but that individual personality profile is going to contribute to the dynamic. Personally, I believe that the best combination for a roommate is someone who is conscientious, honest, open to experience, agreeable, and hopefully low on neuroticism, which means that they are emotionally stable, and they deal with
在这五种大五人格特质中，我们每个人都位于它们各自光谱的某个位置。如果你做过迈尔斯-布里格斯性格测试，你可以根据这种组合来确定你是什么样的人，以及你在群居环境中会是什么样的人。也许你是艺人、高管、调解人、辩论家、指挥官。我不知道你是哪一种，但那个独特的人格档案将为这种动态做出贡献。就个人而言，我认为室友的最佳组合是一个尽责、诚实、对经验开放、宜人，且神经质较低的人，这意味着他们在情绪上是稳定的，并且能很好地处理
stress well. And one of the worst combinations is someone who we would call high conflict. I think we all have an idea of what a high conflict individual looks like. We've probably all met one. This is someone who loves drama. And they have this pattern of increasing tension, increasing like the mellow drama of an environment rather than reducing it or resolving it. This pattern usually happens over and over again in many different situations with many different people. They blame others. They don't care about boundaries. They never feel like they've done anything wrong. They are extreme and they always prefer to prioritize themselves over like the collective well-being and comfort of the home. For example, I had a roommate like this who would throw parties all the time and I
压力。而最糟糕的组合之一是那种我们称之为“高冲突”的人。我想我们大家对高冲突个体长什么样都有个概念。我们可能都遇到过这样的人。这是一种热爱戏剧性事件的人。他们有一种模式，会加剧紧张局势，增加环境中的情节剧色彩，而不是减少或解决它。这种模式通常在许多不同的情况下、与许多不同的人反复发生。他们责怪他人。他们不在乎界限。他们从不觉得自己做错了什么。他们很极端，而且总是倾向于把自己的利益置于家庭的集体福祉和舒适之上。例如，我有过这样一个室友，他总是开派对，而我
honestly got to the point where I think he just enjoyed us getting angry at him. Like he liked being the villain in the house for some weird neurological, psychological, psychological, reason. I think some people are just more conflict prone compared to others, those of us who are conflict-averse running away from disagreements or frustration. But honestly, either end of that spectrum is equally harmful when we're talking about living in a shared home. Obviously, it's extremely difficult to live with someone who has like no respect for other people and is always wanting to argue. But then we also have that roommate who is mad about something, is annoyed at doing all the cleaning or people not paying bills on time, and they say nothing about it. They keep it to
老实说，事情发展到后来，我觉得他其实挺喜欢我们对他生气的。就好像出于某种怪异的神经学、心理学、心理学原因，他喜欢成为家里的恶人。我认为有些人与其他人相比，天生就更容易引发冲突，而我们当中有些人则逃避冲突，逃避分歧或挫折。但老实说，当我们在谈论合租生活时，这个光谱的任何一端都是同样有害的。显然，和一个完全不尊重他人、总是想吵架的人住在一起极其困难。但接着我们也会有这样的室友：他们对某事感到生气，对包揽了所有清洁工作或者别人不按时交账单感到恼火，但他们对此只字不提。他们把情绪藏在
themselves, but it shows up in other ways. Like they stonewall you or they ice you out. I think it's hard because the people we live with don't have the same conflict style as us. But also sometimes when, you know, we don't have the same comfort as we would with a family member. So we feel really awkward bringing things up. You know, perhaps if it's a stranger and you just feel like it would be really inappropriate to have those kinds of conversations or even worse is when they are a friend and we worry that a small disagreement to do with like house upkeep or lifestyles or whatever is going to impact our relationship as friends beyond our relationship as roommates. this brings me to, I think, one of my biggest points. Moving in with friends. This is such a big risk.
心里，但它会以其他方式表现出来。比如他们会对你采取冷战或者把你晾在一边。我认为这很艰难，因为我们住在一起的人和我们没有相同的冲突风格。而且有时，（你知道的）当我们没有像对待家庭成员那样轻松的心态时，我们会觉得提起这些事情真的很尴尬。你知道，也许如果对方是个陌生人，你会觉得进行那种对话真的非常不合适；或者更糟糕的是，当他们是你的朋友时，我们会担心与房屋维护、生活方式等有关的小分歧，会影响到我们作为朋友的关系，而不仅仅是我们作为室友的关系。这就引出了我认为我的最大观点之一：和朋友合租。这真的是一个巨大的风险。
Let me just tell you that now. I also think that it is a mistake that I've made in the past, but I've also had really great success stories. I lived with two of my closest friends for almost two years. We never had a single problem because our lifestyles, our expectations for each other, our communication styles, they all lined up. But I think sometimes we want to live with friends more than strangers because of that familiarity, right?
现在就让我这么告诉你们吧。我也认为这是我过去犯过的一个错误，但我也经历过非常成功的案例。我曾和两个最要好的朋友合住了将近两年。我们从来没有出过任何问题，因为我们的生活方式、我们对彼此的期望、我们的沟通风格，全都很合拍。但我认为有时我们比起陌生人更想和朋友合租，是因为那种熟悉感，对吧？
It feels like less of a risk because we already know that, you know, like, we at least like this person. But there's also an equal risk that moving in together is going to cost you the relationship because it will change the dynamic either by increasing like the intensity of your closeness, sometimes causing codependency or making it such that small conflicts in the home begin to affect your bigger relationship as friends. Living together in a shared environment that you have mutual responsibility towards changes the dynamic. When the quarters are that close, there is more room for tension, like just a small spark of anger or frustration if it's not taken care of is going to spiral. And I have friends who I understand I just couldn't live with.
这感觉风险较小，因为我们已经知道（你知道的）至少我们喜欢这个人。但这也存在同等的风险，即搬到一起住可能会毁掉你们的关系，因为它会改变彼此相处的动态：有时会通过增加亲密程度导致相互依赖，或者让家里的微小冲突开始影响你们作为朋友的更大关系。在一个你们共同承担责任的共享环境中生活会改变这种动态。当空间如此狭窄时，就有更多的空间产生紧张感，哪怕是一小点愤怒或挫折的火花，如果不加以处理，也会急剧升级。我有一些朋友，我明白我就是无法和他们住在一起。
It doesn't mean that I don't love them. It's just that we acknowledge that our living styles, how much downtime we need, our levels of cleanliness, they're different. And putting our relationship in like the absolute pressure cooker that is living together would be, I think, disastrous and destructive. Some of us obviously don't realize that until it's way too late. And that's what leads to conflict. Conflict in a sharehouse is inevitable the same way that it's inevitable in a workplace or a family home in a romantic relationship.
这并不意味着我不爱他们。只是我们承认，我们的生活方式、我们需要多少独处时间、我们的清洁程度是不同的。而且把我们的关系置于同居这种绝对的高压锅环境中，我认为将是灾难性和破坏性的。当然，我们中的一些人直到为时已晚才意识到这一点。而这正是导致冲突的原因。合租屋中的冲突是不可避免的，就像在职场、家庭或恋爱关系中冲突不可避免一样。
But I think the biggest sources in this specific situation are obviously mess, roommates who are disrespectful as well when we speak to them about mess. People not really doing their part, borrowing things without asking first, people not paying their bills on time or not paying a fair share for commonly. used items, people who are really noisy, and then people who are really, really controlling of the environment. Once again, a lot of this comes down to not just personality differences, of course, but differences in how we were raised. And when that bubbles up, it becomes really unpleasant, and it can actually have really serious consequences for our mental health. There have been like countless studies on this because we understand that there is an important relationship between our living environment and our mental state or our emotional well-being.
但我认为这种特定情况下冲突的最大根源显然是杂乱、室友在我们跟他们谈论杂乱时表现出的不尊重。人们没有做好自己分内的事、未经允许擅自借用东西、人们不按时交账单或者没有为公共用品支付公平的份额，非常吵闹的人，以及对环境控制欲极强的人。再一次，这很大程度上不仅归结于性格差异，当然还有成长经历的差异。当这些情绪爆发时，会变得非常令人不快，并且实际上会对我们的心理健康产生非常严重的后果。这方面已经有了无数的研究，因为我们明白我们的居住环境与我们的精神状态或情绪健康之间存在着重要的关系。
Like it is our place of rest, it's our home. It's where we should feel most calm and safe. But when that environment is disturbed or not to our liking, we see massive consequences. People who are fighting with their roommates no longer feel the sense of security that they need from their home environment. We don't feel like we are allowed to relax or be ourselves in the home. And if we can't do those things in our house, where are we going to do that? We never have like a time or a place to turn off, to switch off. The worst case of this is when it's not just that it gets to the point of like full on blowouts, but when it gets to the point where people are completely avoiding each other in common spaces, it's like they're playing like an unspoken game of,
这就像是我们的休息场所，是我们的家。这是我们应该感到最平静和最安全的地方。但当那个环境受到干扰或不合我们的心意时，我们就会看到巨大的后果。与室友吵架的人再也感受不到他们对家庭环境所需要的那种安全感。我们觉得我们在家里不被允许放松或做自己。如果我们连在自己家里都做不到这些，我们又能在哪里做到呢？我们从来没有一个时间或地点可以关闭、可以切换状态。这种情况最糟糕的时候，不仅是发展到全面爆发的争吵，而是人们开始在公共空间里彻底避开彼此，就像是在玩一场心照不宣的游戏：
of hide and seek with each other. It feels like you're a stranger in your own home. You're constantly locked in your room. Your anxiety is spiked. You feel hypervigilant or stressed whenever you perceive that there is like a threat in the environment. Right? Like you're cooking dinner and then like suddenly this person walks in and you don't say anything to each other. And it's awkward and it's painful.
彼此就像在玩捉迷藏。你感觉自己就像个异乡人，待在自己的家里。你时刻躲在房间里锁着门。你的焦虑情绪激增。每当你觉得环境中存在某种威胁时，你就会感到高度警惕或压力倍增。对吧？比如你正在做晚饭，然后这个人突然走了进来，你们俩一句话也不说。这种气氛既尴尬又痛苦。
Another story for you guys once again about Dirty Dishes Man because he is obviously infamous when it comes to my sharehouse experiences. but by the end of like living together, we would go entire weeks without speaking a word to the other person. And at that point, we lived in a three bedroom house with five people in it. And it was during COVID. So it wasn't like we didn't see each other. But it got to the point where he had just overstepped so many boundaries. He had caused so much pain and obviously didn't respect the other people living in the house that there was. was no point trying to repair what was broken or even be civil about it. And in those situations,
再跟大家讲一个关于“脏盘子男”的故事，他在我的合租经历中显然“大名鼎鼎”。但到了我们同居的后期，我们甚至可以整整几个星期和对方说不上一句话。当时，我们住在一个三居室的房子里，里面住了五个人。那是疫情期间。所以并不是说我们见不到彼此。但情况发展到那一步，是因为他越界的次数实在太多了。他带来了那么多的痛苦，而且显然不尊重屋里的其他人，所以……根本没有必要再去试图修复已经破裂的关系，甚至连维持表面的客套都省了。在这种情况下，
you kind of have three options, right? Either you move out, they move out, or you swallow your pride and you get to the bottom of it. The last option is obviously the hardest because sometimes it feels like once again, we have to be the bigger person and we're sick of doing that. We don't want to be the peacemaker all the time or carry the mental load. So we just become resigned to how things are. And that's when the house starts to crumble. Because there is no longer that, not just positive, but transparent communication. And I think if you don't set that up at the beginning, if you don't build that routine of talking about your problems, if you don't set those ground rules, when the time does come, that frustration, tension, conflict does emerge.
你基本上有三种选择，对吧？要么你搬走，要么他们搬走，要么你放下自尊，把事情彻底弄清楚。最后一种选择显然是最难的，因为有时你会觉得，我们又得扮演那个懂事的大人了，而我们已经厌倦了这样做。我们不想一直当和事佬，也不想承担所有的心理负担。于是我们只能对现状逆来顺受。而这正是这个屋子开始分崩离析的时候。因为那种不仅是积极的、而且是坦诚的沟通已经不复存在了。我想，如果你在一开始就没有建立起这种机制，如果你没有养成讨论问题的常规，如果你没有立下这些基本原则，那么当真正需要的时候，那种挫败感、紧张感和冲突感就会爆发出来。
you're kind of going into it with no rulebook or really no understanding of the other person's expectations or perspective. So what I really want to discuss next is how we can actually make it so we never get to that point, how we can have a positive sharehouse experience, the dream sharehouse experience, all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. later available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
你进入这种状态时，可以说是毫无规则可言，对对方的期望或视角也一无所知。所以接下来我真正想讨论的是，我们究竟该如何做到永远不让关系恶化到那一步，如何拥有一段积极的合租体验、梦想中的合租体验，所有这些以及更多精彩内容，将在短暂的广告之后为您揭晓。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。稍后播出。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你抛开那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经深信植物油具有天然的致炎性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。听听《2%》吧。这就是可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听的《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在MTV音乐录影带大奖上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
（此处原文有重复，略过翻译中的重复部分，保持与原文块一一对应）
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑鬼的时候。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论着80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病这个话题摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾进行了对话。我谈到了。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于我们没有意识到自己其实已经拥有了它。但我们依然在追逐，而且不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。你觉得在这个世上当一个好人很重要吗？你当好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself.
因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层级。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己
at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones.
身处一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法院听证会暴露出她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Michael Sbee and Michael Maranini.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。迈克尔·斯比和迈克尔·马拉尼尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
podcasts. So let's talk about what it means to be a good roommate and the ways we can hopefully avoid that kind of all too common experience of the sharehouse going up in flames. Like not literal flames, emotional flames. We want to be on speaking terms with the people who live in our home. We want to avoid the silent treatment or breaking the lease or a million other less than ideal ways that this can end. So the first step really begins before you even sign the lease. right? Like the biggest error people make is not actually asserting their standards beforehand. Their standards for cleanliness, for a loan time, for noise, for bills, for splitting expenses, for even minor things like, when are you going to turn the aircon on during the year or the heating?
所以我们来谈谈做一个好室友意味着什么，以及我们如何才能有望避免那种合租屋着火般的老套经历。不是字面意义上的着火，是情感上的着火。我们希望和住在我们屋檐下的人保持能够正常交流的关系。我们希望避免冷暴力、撕毁租约，或是其他数百万种不太理想的结局。所以第一步其实在你签租约之前就已经开始了。对吧？比如人们犯的最大错误，就是在事前没有真正明确自己的标准。他们对清洁度、独处时间、噪音、账单、分摊费用的标准，甚至是一些微小的事情，比如：你一年里什么时候会开空调或暖气？
Every point of ambiguity is a potential point of conflict. My dad actually gave me this incredible tip when I first moved into a sharehouse. He told me that we need to sit down, all of us, write out our house rules. And everyone had to agree. Everyone had to sign off on the rules. And then they went on the fridge and they were basically never discussed again unless someone, quote unquote, broke the rules. Then it was never a discussion of like, oh, I didn't know. Oh, I was confused. They had agreed to the rules. They'd broken them consciously. They'd broken the like roommate contract. And obviously it was then up to them to apologize and make up for it. There are, though, sometimes some people who believe that rules are need to be broken.
每一个模糊不清的地方，都是潜在的冲突点。我刚搬进合租屋时，我爸爸给了我一个绝妙的建议。他告诉我们，所有人必须坐下来，写下我们的家规。每个人都必须同意。每个人都必须在规则上签字。然后它们被贴在冰箱上，基本上就再也没有被讨论过，除非有人“违反”了规则。那时候就不会再有诸如“哦，我不知道”、“哦，我搞糊涂了”之类的讨论。他们已经同意了这些规则。他们是有意违反的。他们违反了室友契约。很显然，接下来就轮到他们道歉并做出弥补了。不过，有时确实有些人认为规则就是用来打破的。
I think in those instances when you have a roommate like that, instead of just like pushing again and again and reminding them again and again and just becoming exhausted when they don't listen, the trick is to find out what this person actually cares about, what causes them to act in a certain way. There is something that matters to them and if you can link the behavior that you need from them with, what matters to them, then you have a chance to actually make something happen. For example, if they are someone who really likes or needs the approval of others, make it known that when they keep things tidy, it makes you really happy and appreciative. Maybe it's that they have a real sense of duty or fairness, really reinforce them, like the duty of being a good roommate. Maybe it's guilt, whatever. Find what motivates them and leverage that. But as this therapist, Dr. Fitzpatrick said in her incredible article about this, I'll link it below. Sometimes there are people who just
我想在那种情况下，当你遇到这样的室友时，与其一次又一次地催促，一次又一次地提醒他们，结果在他们不听时感到精疲力竭，不如诀窍在于去找出这个人真正在乎的是什么，是什么促使他做出某种行为。总会有某些事情是对他们很重要的，如果你能把你需要的他们的行为与他们真正在乎的事情联系起来，那么你就有机会真正促成一些改变。例如，如果他们是一个非常喜欢或需要别人认可的人，那就让他们知道，当他们保持环境整洁时，会让你感到非常开心和感激。也许他们有着强烈的责任感或公平感，那就不断强化这一点，比如做一个好室友的责任。也许是负罪感，不管是什么。找到他们的动机并加以利用。但正如这位治疗师菲茨帕特里克博士在她关于此事的精彩文章中所说的那样，我会在下方链接。有时有些人只是
are not really caught up in the rules of engagement here. They kind of need to be gently reminded that to be human is to sometimes have to be cooperative and to compromise. We often really like to believe in the goodness of others, but sometimes you just encounter people who have a different agenda. When we're talking about that level of inconsideration, often what's behind that, is some sort of resentment, hurt, anger, it could just be pure laziness because they've been babyed all of their life. And what you need to do as a house is kind of, unfortunately, I know it sounds unfair, but you're the one who now has to help them realize that this is where it stops. I think it's very rare that you end up living with like a total psychopath. I don't know,
并不太在乎这里的交往规则。他们需要被温和地提醒，身为人类，有时就必须学会合作和妥协。我们通常非常愿意相信他人的善良，但有时你确实会遇到一些有着不同议程的人。当我们谈论那种缺乏考虑的程度时，通常在这背后的，是某种怨恨、伤害、愤怒，或者仅仅是因为他们一辈子都被当成婴儿般照顾而产生的纯粹的懒惰。作为这个家的一员，你需要做的是，虽然听起来很不公平，但你得去帮助他们意识到，不能再这样下去了。我认为你最终和一个彻头彻尾的精神病患者住在一起的几率是非常小的。我不知道，
maybe you have a story for me, and that has been your experience. But the majority of people still respond to human emotion. So if you tell them how their actions have impacted you, how they've left you feeling, disrespected, if they've left you feeling upset, most people don't want to be that person. They don't want to be the household villain. That is the wake-up call that they need.
也许你有这样的故事，而这就是你的经历。但大多数人对人类的情感仍然是有反应的。所以如果你告诉他们他们的行为对你产生了什么影响，让他们知道这让你感到不受尊重，让他们知道这让你感到心烦意乱，大多数人其实并不想成为那样的人。他们不想成为全屋的恶人。这就是他们需要的警钟。
Honesty and vulnerability. And I know it's really hard to put yourself in a position where you have to be vulnerable with someone, especially if you don't know them, especially if it's a little bit awkward. But I think vulnerability always has a lot of rules. rewards that come with it. And you know what? You might not feel like best friends now, but keeping open those kind of lines of communication when you're living under the same roof is really
诚实和脆弱。我知道，要把自己置于一个必须对某人展现脆弱的境地真的很难，尤其是当你们不认识彼此的时候，尤其是当气氛还有点尴尬的时候。但我认为，展现脆弱总会带来丰厚的回报。你知道吗？你们现在可能不会觉得彼此是最好的朋友，但在同一个屋檐下生活时，保持这种沟通渠道的畅通真的是
essential. If you are the one though, who is the source of frustration, you have been told that you are not pulling your fair share, you're not contributing, you're not keeping things clean, remember, this is not them expressing unconditional anger at you. They are speaking to you about this in order to give you an opportunity to improve and adjust. The worst thing we can do is interpret boundary setting and like basic respectful discussion as an insult or a take down as criticism and allow ourselves to react from a place of defensiveness. That is when we, I think, see irreparable conflict. When we feel threatened or confronted, often our first primal instinct is to
至关重要的。不过，如果你恰恰是那个引发挫败感的人，别人已经指出你没有承担起公平的份额，你没有做出贡献，你没有保持环境清洁，请记住，这不是他们对你表达无条件的愤怒。他们跟你谈论这件事，是为了给你一个改进和调整的机会。我们能做的最糟糕的事情，就是把设定界限和基本的尊重讨论当成一种侮辱、打击或批评，并允许自己从防御的心态出发做出反应。我想，那正是我们看到无法修复的冲突爆发的时候。当我们感到受到威胁或对立时，我们往往最初的本能反应是
defend ourselves at all costs by minimizing the other person's feelings, feeling like they are unjustified or really digging our heels in. It's very primitive and psychologists often point to the role of our self-esteem in those moments where we don't want to feel like we're a bad person so to regulate that cognitive dissonance. We put the problem back on someone else. That instinct is not helping you. In fact, I would argue that it's highly counterpriced. productive in this situation. Instead, accept accountability in those moments. Make a plan to be better. Make a plan to hold yourself accountable that doesn't disturb the peace any further. Because we all have a shared goal here, right? We have a shared goal of like peace and harmony. And I know that sounds cheesy,
不惜一切代价为自己辩护，贬低对方的感受，觉得他们的指责毫无道理，或者顽固地坚持己见。这非常原始，心理学家经常指出我们在那些时刻的自尊心所起的作用，我们不想觉得自己是个坏人，为了调节这种认知失调，我们把问题重新推回给别人。这种本能对你没有任何帮助。事实上，我认为在这种情况下，它是极其适得其反的。相反，要在那些时刻接受责任。制定一个变得更好的计划。制定一个对自己负责的计划，并且不要再进一步破坏平静。因为我们在这里都有一个共同的目标，对吧？我们都有一个追求和平与和谐的共同目标。我知道这听起来很陈词滥调，
but honestly, that is what we all want at the end of the day to be able to come home to our home and feel like it's fun and feel like it's that we're meant to be there and feel safe. That brings me to my next tip. Although you don't have to be best friends with someone just because you live in the same home, it doesn't hurt by any means to have like some kind of social contact. Familiarity is such an amazing bonding, emotion and experience. You don't want to be like the avoiding type. You don't want to live in a house of like of ghosts where the silence is like super deafening and it's really, really lonely.
但说实话，这才是我们终究想要的：能够回到自己的家，觉得这里很有趣，觉得这里就是我们该呆的地方，并且感到安全。这就引出了我的下一个建议。尽管你不需要仅仅因为住在同一个屋檐下就和别人成为最好的朋友，但进行某种形式的社交接触绝对没有坏处。熟悉感是一种非常奇妙的凝聚情感和体验。你不想成为那种逃避型的人。你不想住在一个像鬼屋一样、寂静得震耳欲聋、而且极其孤独的房子里。
So I think frequent casual contact, social contact is a really nice way to just bond and stay friendly with each other. We used to do Sunday dinners each week and everyone was responsible for like some part of the meal and then we would play board games and have a wine and just chat or go to trivia and bingo host parties together. And then it didn't feel like we were just all these strangers who had suddenly been placed in like a house together and had to just like find a way to get along. Like we could actually be friends. We could actually turn to one another. So I'm not going to talk about cleaning rosters or anything to do with bills or splitting things
所以我觉得频繁的随意的接触、社交接触，真的是一种增进感情和保持彼此友好关系的绝佳方式。我们过去每周日都会聚餐，每个人负责聚餐的一部分，然后我们玩桌游、喝点红酒、随意聊天，或者一起去参加益智问答和宾果游戏派对。这样一来，我们就不会觉得自己只是一群突然被塞进同一个屋檐下、不得不设法相处陌生人了。我们真的可以成为朋友。我们真的可以向彼此倾诉。所以我不会去谈论清洁值日表或任何与账单或分摊费用有关的事情，
because I think we know the drill, right? Like I feel like that is something we all have a pretty good understanding of. But I do have two final tips. Firstly, don't form groups within the house. Don't gossip about one house member solely with another member of the house. bring up your grievances in person because you don't want to create a collective enemy here. It's shit for everybody. You don't want to exclude someone.
因为我想我们都门清，对吧？我觉得那是我们所有人都有相当好理解的东西。但我还有最后两个建议。首先，不要在房子里拉帮结派。不要只跟房子里的某一个成员去八卦另一个成员。要把你的不满当面提出来，因为你绝对不想在这里树立一个共同的敌人。这对谁都没有好处。你不想孤立任何人。
I've had sharehouses or friends in sharehouses where there's been like three members of the house and two of them have become super close and just excluded the third person. Don't be that person. It's giving high school bully. It keeps people isolated and it builds resentment. And secondly, don't. And I mean, do not sleep with your room. We have all heard the horror stories here.
我经历过合租屋，或者我有朋友在合租屋里，里面有三个成员，其中两个变得超级亲密，却把第三个人排挤在外。别做那种人。这散发着高中霸凌者的气息。它会让人感到孤立，并滋生怨恨。其次，千万不要。我的意思是，绝对不要和你的室友发生性关系。我们在这一行听过太多恐怖故事了。
The second you cross that platonic line, all rules disappear, all boundaries are gone. It's like you've basically moved in together after your first date. Not a great start for a healthy relationship if that's what you want. And if it's not what you want, then it's just really awkward. Because then suddenly your other roommates feel like they're living with this couple that has this weird like past, or not quite a couple at all. There's so much that can go wrong. There's other people involved.
一旦你跨越了那条柏拉图式的界限，所有的规则都会消失，所有的边界都会不复存在。这就好比你们在第一次约会后就直接同居了一样。如果你想要的是一段健康的恋爱关系，这可不是一个好的开始。如果这不是你想要的，那就会变得非常尴尬。因为突然之间，你的其他室友会觉得他们是在和一个有着某种诡异过去、或者根本算不上情侣的情侣住在一起。可能会出错的事情太多了。还有其他人卷入其中。
You never get the space you need. when you've just started out, like, bad idea, please trust me on this. So our final discussion point for the day is when do you know it's time to leave the sharehouse life behind and live alone? I really believe that everyone should live at loan at least once. And I know it's such a privilege to say that. But if it is within your means, the benefits are really endless. You learn to value your own company.
当你刚开始的时候，你永远得不到自己需要的空间——这绝对是个坏主意，请相信我。所以我们今天的最后一个讨论点是：什么时候你才知道是时候把合租生活抛在脑后，开始独居了？我真的相信每个人都应该至少独居一次。我也知道说这话是一种特权。但如果你的经济条件允许，独居的好处真的是无穷无尽的。你学会了珍惜自己的陪伴，
you get to decide like exactly how you want to live, you have that independence and autonomy of your space. I think although the solitude can sometimes be really scary, and that's a reason why a lot of us don't do it, it's also really important to do scary things every now and again. And to prove to yourself that you're capable of loving your own life, loving your own company, loving your own space. When you live alone, you have that time to really focus
你可以自己决定究竟想怎样生活，你对自己的空间拥有那种独立性和自主性。我认为，虽然独孤有时会让人感到非常害怕，这也是我们很多人选择不独居的原因，但偶尔做做让人害怕的事情同样非常重要。向自己证明你有能力热爱自己的生活，热爱自己的陪伴，热爱自己的空间。当你独居时，你就有时间真正专注于
on who you are. I think it leads to a lot of increased self-awareness because you're not just able to distract yourself with very convenient, like, social interaction. It also comes down to what you're willing to kind of compromise. Every decision or change like this inevitably comes with sacrifice, but do you, you know, but it's about really what you value. It's about what you're willing to give up for the benefits. Like, do you value your alone time more or the conditions? Or the convenience of company. Would giving up that built-in social interaction be harder for you than having to give up a certain level of privacy and autonomy? That's really an equation that only you can do, a decision only you can make. But I do think there are some pretty big signs that you are,
你是谁。我认为这会带来大大增强的自我意识，因为你不会仅仅通过非常便利的社交互动来分散自己的注意力。这也归结为你愿意在多大程度上做出妥协。每一个这样的决定或改变都不可避免地伴随着牺牲，但这归根结底取决于你珍视什么。这关乎你愿意为了这些好处而放弃什么。比如，你更看重自己的独处时间，还是环境条件？或是陪伴的便利性。放弃这种现成的社交互动，对你来说会不会比放弃一定程度的隐私和自主权更难？这真的是一个只有你能解答的等式，一个只有你能做出的决定。但我确实认为，有一些非常明显的迹象表明你已经，
you're ready to take that leap. Firstly, A, you have the financial means to do it. That's just like a number one point here. You have to do like a big financial overhaul, I think, a bit of an audit, a bit of an investigation, and just make sure you actually have enough leeway to be able to afford a solo lifestyle. Because it naturally will be more expensive. You don't want to live by yourself for like seven months, realize you can no longer afford it and have to go back. But you've already like gotten a taste of like of a sweeter fruit. You've already like begun to adapt to this kind of way of living. And suddenly you're back in like the sharehouse with like four people who don't know how to wash their dishes.
你已经准备好迈出这一步了。首先，A，你有这样做的经济实力。这绝对是排在第一位的。我认为你必须进行一次重大的财务整顿，做一点审计，做一点调查，确保你确实有足够的资金空间来负担独居的生活方式。因为它自然会更昂贵。你可不想自己住上七个月，然后发现再也负担不起，不得不搬回去。但你却已经尝到了更甜美的果实的滋味。你已经开始适应这种生活方式了。然后突然之间你又回到了合租屋里，和四个甚至不知道怎么洗碗的人住在一起。
Secondly, another reason is if you are increasingly irritated by the presence of others, you find yourself hermining, you're avoiding your roommates. Thirdly, if you have the social supports and like the social circle to enable you to spend more time just alone in your home without feeling disconnected, D, you need more space for yourself, like just literal physical space, like storage space, not emotional space. E, if your relationship is getting serious and you know that the next step may be to live together, but you want to have that solo living experience before then. And finally, if you're just ready for the freedom, that's huge to me at the moment. As long with that, the reason I gave before, like my relationship is getting serious.
其次，另一个原因是你越来越对别人的存在感到烦躁，你发现自己开始宅在房里不出门，你在躲着室友。第三，如果你拥有能够支持你在家中花更多时间独处而不会感到与世隔绝的社会支持和社交圈。D，你需要为自己争取更多的空间，比如字面意义上的物理空间，像储物空间，而不是情感空间。E，如果你的恋爱关系变得严肃起来，你知道下一步可能就是同居，但你想在此之前先体验一下独居生活。最后，如果你已经准备好迎接自由——这对我目前来说意义重大。除此之外，就像我之前给出的原因一样，我的恋爱关系变得严肃起来。
I'm kind of like, oh, like we are going to end up living together. Before we do that, I want to live alone. I think living alone has always been a really huge goal for me because I have a really deep fear of being alone. And I want to challenge that at least once in my life and stop letting that fear kind of control me and keep me in a place of depending on other people for company and comfort, even when actually what I would rather do is just be by myself,
我心里想，哦，我们最后还是要同居的。在那之前，我想先体验一下独居。我认为独居一直是我一个非常巨大的目标，因为我内心对孤独有着非常深层的恐惧。我想在我的生命中至少挑战它一次，不再让这种恐惧控制我，不再让我为了陪伴和安慰而依附于其他人，哪怕实际上我更想做的事情只是一个人呆着，
but I'm so like almost addicted to that very, validation of having other people around me. That has just gone way too deep. They're very vulnerable, but honestly, I feel like I'm not the only one who has that experience. Sharehouses, as a conclusion, can be great, but they're also just inherently a bit of like a mental labyrinth and a bit of a hassle at times. It is like so strangely intimate when you think about it. Like the home is normally something reserved for like a family or people who are like in love. and now it's reserved for like people who like sometimes don't even know each other
但我几乎对那种周围有人陪伴的表层认可上瘾了。这种心态已经根深蒂固了。这些想法非常脆弱，但老实说，我觉得有这种经历的人绝不止我一个。总而言之，合租屋可以很棒，但它们本质上也是一个情感的迷宫，有时确实是个麻烦。仔细想想，这真是一种诡异的亲密。家通常是为家庭或相爱的人保留的。而现在它却成了那些有时甚至互不相识的人的住所
and suddenly you're like asleep in the next room. You know, like I said at the beginning, putting a bunch of people in a house and expecting it to just work is like so implausible. They literally have TV shows about that very premise. Like that is what Big Brother is about. That's like how fascinating it is. That's how interesting the dynamics get. So if you're living with roommates now and they're just kind of getting on your nerves,
然后你突然就睡在隔壁房间。你知道的，就像我一开始说的，把一群人塞进一个房子里，还指望它能自然运转，这简直太不合情理了。他们甚至专门拍了关于这种前提的电视真人秀。这就是《老大哥》节目的内容。这就是它的迷人之处。这就是人际动态变得如此有趣的地方。所以如果你现在正和室友住在一起，而他们刚好在惹你心烦，
you're in the midst of some like weird tension. I feel you, we've all been there. Sometimes it is a dream and it's super fun. Other times it's just frustrating. But I also think it is an important experience of our 20s to at least have those moments because then you'll never take your alone time for granted ever again. One of my friends said to me, like, she was like to me,
你正处在某种诡异的紧张气氛中，我能理解你，我们都经历过。有时它是个梦想，超级有趣。而有时它只是令人沮丧。但我也认为，在我们二十几岁的年纪里，至少经历这些时刻是一段很重要的体验，因为那样你将永远不会再把独处的时间当作理所当然。我的一个朋友对我说，她对我说，
what did she say? She's like, I want to push myself to the point of like absolutely hating my sharehousing so that I never want to go back. And so that I'm never like in my 30s or 40s being like, oh, I shouldn't have spent more time in my sharehouse. Like, I think we've all been there. We've all been at that point. So I really hope that you enjoy this episode.
她当时说了什么？她说，我想要把自己逼到对合租生活感到彻底厌恶的程度，这样我就再也不想回去了。这样我在三十多岁或四十多岁时就不会说，哦，我不该在合租屋里花那么多时间的。我觉得我们都经历过。我们都曾到达过那个节点。所以我真的希望你们能喜欢这一集。
Remember, if you're having a shit time right now, everything is temporary. And I hope you just, like, learnt something about how roommates and sharehouses and communal spaces operate. It is so psychological. It comes down to, like, so many strange theories about people's personalities and ways of life and how they were raised. So it's no wonder that I think so much drama and tension, but also so many good times come from the Shirehouse. So thank you so much for listening. I think I've already said this, but I do really hope that you've enjoyed this episode. If you have a roommate horror story, send it my way.
记住，如果你现在正经历一段糟糕的时光，一切都是暂时的。我希望你能从中了解到室友、合租屋和公共空间是如何运作的。这其中包含着太多的心理学。它归结为关于人们的性格、生活方式以及他们的成长经历的种种奇奇怪怪的理论。所以毫无疑问，我认为合租屋里会产生那么多的戏剧性和紧张气氛，但也会诞生那么多的美好时光。非常感谢大家的收听。我想我之前已经说过这番话了，但我真的希望你们能喜欢这一集。如果你有什么室友恐怖故事，发给我吧。
Maybe we'll do like a follow-up episode just talking about roommate horror stories. I feel like I'm also just nosy and I want to know what you guys have been through. So if you enjoyed this episode and you feel like there's a little bit of you feel like there. is someone else who might benefit from it. Please feel free to share a link with them or leave a five-star review. Wherever you're listening right now, I read every single review that is left for me. And they're really amazing. It's such a beautiful point of encouragement, a beautiful part of like my week to have a little
也许我们会做一期后续节目，专门聊聊室友的恐怖故事。我觉得我也只是有点八卦，想知道你们都经历过什么。所以如果你喜欢这一集，并且觉得你身边可能也有人能从中受益。请随时将链接分享给他们，或者留下五星好评。无论你现在在哪里收听，我都会阅读留给我的每一条评论。它们真的太棒了。这是一种巨大的鼓励，也是我每周生活中非常美妙的一部分。
read. And yeah, it's just super lovely that there are so many of you out there who love this show. So thank you for supporting me so much recently. Make sure you're following so that when we released. New episodes, they are delivered right to your feed. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
是的，有这么多的人喜欢这个节目，这真的是太美妙了。谢谢你们最近对我的大力支持。请确保你点击了关注，这样当新节目发布时，它们就会直接发送到你的动态里。一如既往，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a half, happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。听听《2%》吧。这就是可在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听的《TWA%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和意义重大。
84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。在那之前，那是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are honest? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯为你主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一套西装却很诚实？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，埃伦斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。